my name is abida i'm from geek culture
um i was at the conference earlier and
you said that you thought raya was a
live action film
what was your reaction when you learned
that you were gonna voice an animated
dragon instead
uh well no i mean okay well what i meant
was that when we went to um d23 we we
saw like clips of it it was the first
time i saw any clips from the movie and
it was rain
coming down on ryan's feet you could see
ryan's feet and i was like is this a
live-action movie did they not tell me
just because the the animation was so
good um but but but yeah i mean when i
first got um the
the uh
the
the call to voice sisu i mean i it was
it was so
i was mind-blowing i almost didn't
believe it i like didn't believe that
this was a real call you know maybe like
maybe they want to now but like who
knows if they still want me later um but
then you know there are all these other
like i've always really connected with
dragons born in the year the dragon you
know and and so uh i just think it it's
it's a it's a really if i was ever going
to play an animal it's a cool animal to
play
it's definitely really really
i think like i've heard that people were
comparing you to the
genie from aladdin so i think that's a
really big compliment yeah it is a big
it's a little bit of a too big
compliment because people people bring
it up and i'm like what am i like like i
mean you know how how can you how can
you compete with well robin williams is
genie that's an iconic character you
know but they are big they are both big
and blue so i i could see that there
yeah
before you went actress you were a
rapper um
can you do me the honor of restyling
what raya the last dragon is all about
oh man i'm such a bad freestyler um uh
i can maybe do it
um is
okay all right all right are you on you
want you want to experience how bad of a
freestyler i am okay here we go
ready
ryan the last dragon is a really great
movie
so bring your friends
for the fooby
[Laughter]
you did better than me
thank you thank you uh
by the way not a word um
so just yeah know that it's great
maybe i'll put it in my article i'll
just say
word of the year
movie
just we just call it movie oh man
it's great
you know you're currently on a roll
you're not only in raya you're gonna be
in shanghai you're gonna be in the
little mermaid as well um
congratulations really exciting time
ahead um what's it like to be a woman of
color in this industry and literally be
given or have the opportunity to do all
these roles that you never would have
expected to do when you were much
younger
um i mean i mean it feels uh incredible
but i think you know in terms of of the
timing at which i came into the industry
compared to you know and i've talked to
so many people people i've looked up to
that have been in this industry for many
many years
and uh their their take on how it's
changed is a lot different from when i
came in when i came in you know i was
still able uh the the industry was more
open to kind of diversity into
representation um so you know when i see
the way that they talk about the
industry back then i do realize how
different it is and i also know that
when i was a kid you know i if i had a
kind of a movie like this um
that you know it would have changed the
way that i looked at myself and the way
that i would have looked at at the world
and i think that movies really should
reflect the way that our worlds are and
it's not doing us justice if they don't
so um so yeah it's a really amazing
feeling and i and i feel very proud
that's that's really true because i
never thought i'd be able to see a
southeast asian princess on screen yeah
yeah
yeah so um you know you were here in
singapore for crazy rich asians um when
will you be back for the sequel and
what's the first thing you would do when
you get here
uh the first i cannot wait if i took i
want to come go back to singapore so
badly um
i i would eat go and eat high non
chicken immediately um i would
uh
i'd probably go
i'd probably go to marina bay sands
don't don't talk when i said that
i think that would be i think that would
be a first stop for me um i i love i've
missed singapore every day um i i can't
wait to and hopefully we we get to go
back soon but um i can't wait for it
i hope i hope you do come back and i
hope yeah we need to see you again
sometimes
maybe who knows but yeah i'm down girl
yeah take me out let's do it i remember
that we'll do it i'll just slide it to
your dms okay good let's do it slide be
good
okay thank you so much this is all the
time that i have i wish i had more but
thank you so much for answering all my
questions this is really fun thank you
nice to meet you nice to meet you bye
you